[music playing]
NARRATOR: Of the 429 men who
died on the battleship "USS
Oklahoma," only
35 were identified
in the years immediately
following the attack.
The rest were buried in
graves marked "Unknown."
But almost 75 years later,
one of these unknown men
was given a name.
FAYE HOPKINS BOORE: My
brother's the oldest
so he got the phone call.
And he called me and couldn't
get words out, couldn't speak.
And I knew it was
something important.
And I thought something
happened to somebody.
I said, just spit it
out, just tell me.
And then he said, Uncle
Ed's been identified.
NARRATOR: There is no statute of
limitations on honoring anyone
who died for their country.
The oil that shrouded Pearl
Harbor after the attack
became crucial in
identifying unknown remains.
CAPT. EDWARD REEDY: The fuel
oil has acted as a preservative
for the DNA in these bones.
And we've been able to
get very high-quality DNA
from these skeletal
remains, which has
actually worked in our favor.
If we have the right
family reference samples,
we can successfully
identify all of the unknowns
that we currently
have recovered.
People often ask, is the unknown
soldier a thing of the past.
And the answer to that is yes.
I think it's important to
account for an individual,
to bring that individual
home, and to give them a name.
It's one of my moral
and ethical imperatives
that no one should be
buried without a name.
NARRATOR: On October
15, 2016, Faye Hopkins
Boore was finally
able to lay her uncle
to rest in his hometown.